you know what seems awesome but always
gets a really bad rap the midlife crisis
can we talk about that why are you
always so hard on the midlife crisis
whispering in the shadows like you see
Gary it's so sad
Gary's kids left the house and he bought
a Ferrari
yeah Gary raised three kids got him out
of the house and even managed to save a
few bucks for himself he deserves a
Ferrari right I'm just saying what else
is he supposed to do raise another batch
of kids no you get a Ferrari when the
kids leave that's what you do
buying a Ferrari isn't a crisis driving
a 98 Nissan Quest for 18 years because
you need the space for Ben Ben Bree Bree
and bribry
that's a crisis a Ferrari is a
celebration sports cars are two-seaters
for a reason no room for your three kids
or their six names that's not like you
can get one while you still have kids
they got those gross sticky kid hands
crawling around like I tried to put it
in neutral you're ruling the lot of brat
life what were you harvesting honey show
me those hands
get the two-seater the official vehicle
of the midlife crisis and valet it all
the time even when you don't need to
pulling up to the mall on a Tuesday just
like take good care of my baby even
though there's abundance street parking
and I'm just popping into Wetzel's
pretzels Panther crisis people think
midlife crises are pathetic for some
reason guy turns 50 realizes time as a
flat circle and decides to live it to
the max wire do his neighbors have to be
all like you see Carrie he got an
earring grew a ponytail and I saw
manscaping in the backyard just buzzing
away by the pool what's wrong with that
go out of Gary clean it up down there
maybe there's someone watching this
right now 54 divorced empty nest sitting
on a few retirement bucks wondering if
he should have a midlife crisis well
Gary we're calling all of you Gary I say
thank you should crisis it up grow the
ponytail it's awesome from behind you
look like there's a small horse living
on your neck get the earring which
earring you know the one the single
diamond stud is the perfect choice for
the single diamond stud jeweller gives
you the thumbs-up like it really shows
off your divorce it's your life lose the
gray frost the tips get a bowling shirt
with flames wraparound sunglasses with
the strap that says Jamaican me crazy
go for it basically become Guy Fieri I
don't know why but at 40 something snaps
in a man's brain and suddenly Guy Fieri
makes absolute sense you did your job
you got 240 intact and now you finally
diminished your responsibilities to the
lowest levels they've been since you
were a teenager you deserve the giant
party grill put on the track jacket no
shirt let that chest hair breathe and
perfectly frame that scorpion frozen in
amber still got it medallion
you only live once no I say he only
lived twice it's not Yolo its yote cuz
around 4050 you get to start your life
over that's what a midlife crisis is all
about for 18 years you made scram be egg
for your shitty kids now's the time
order some jewelry from SkyMall carry a
lightsaber get a tattoo a man cave a
little area for you that
have a man house and put all the lame
stuff in the basement I got a man house
now you want the treadmill go downstairs
upstairs it's all ping pong and a
kegerator that looks like Optimus Prime
from a goatee start a Facebook page
follow your kids on Twitter go to your
job and quit cuz you don't got kids you
don't need the extra income and when you
leave don't just walk out ride a Segway
out backwards like yo and when your kids
come home for the holidays you're the
funhouse they're trying to get you to
settle down like that's enough Coke Zero
dad and you're like stop it to net I put
you through college I'm having another
coke beer
leave it up let the neighbors scoff Gary
I get you you just want to revert back
25 years to the last time you felt cool
that's totally fine I personally can't
wait to have a midlife crisis because
that means I get to revert to early 90s
Pete six slap bracelets on one arm three
stripes shaved into one side of my head
and a t-shirt that says stop collaborate
and listen that sounds cool to me